what is marxism what are the defining
characteristics of uh marxism as an
economic and political theory and
ideology
well the simplest way to begin a
definition would be to say it's the
tradition
that takes its
founding inspiration from the works of
karl marx
um
but because
these ideas that he put forward
spread as fast as they did and as
globally as they did
literally it's 140 years since marx died
and in that time his ideas
have become
major
types of thinking
in every country on the earth
if you know much about the great ideas
of human history
that's an extraordinary
spread in an extraordinarily short
period of historical time
and what that has meant that speed of
spread and that geographic diversity
is that the marxian ideas interacted
with
very different cultural histories
religious histories
and economic conditions
so the end result was that the ideas
were interpreted differently
in different places at different times
and therefore marxism
as a kind of first flush definition
is the totality of all of these very
different
ways of coming to terms
with it
for the first
roughly 40 50 years
marxism was a tradition of thinking
critically about capitalism
marx himself that's all he really did he
never wrote a book about communism he
never wrote a book really about
socialism either
his comments were occasional fragmentary
dispersed
what he was really interested in was a
critical analysis of capitalism
and that's what marxism was more or less
in its first 40 or 50 years
um
the only
qualification of what i just said
was something that happened in paris for
a few weeks
in 1871
there was a collapse of the french
government
consequent upon losing a war to
bismarck's germany
and in the result was something called
the paris commune the working class of
paris rose up
basically took over the function of
running
the parisian economy and the parisian
society
and marx's people people influenced by
marx
were very active
in that commune in the leadership of the
commune and marx wasn't that far away he
was in london
these things were happening in paris you
know that's
an easy transport even then
and for a short time
very short
marxism had a different
quality
in addition to being a critique of
capitalism it became
a theory of how to organize society
differently
before that had only been implicit now
it became explicit what is the
leadership of the paris commune going to
do
and why and in what order in other words
governing organizing a society but since
it only lasted a few weeks
the french army regrouped uh and under
the leadership of people who were very
opposed to marx
they
marched back into paris took over killed
a large number of the
of the communards as they were called
and deported them to islands in the
pacific that the that were part of the
french empire at the time
the really big change happens in russia
in 1917. now you have
a group of marxists led in trotsky all
the rest
who
are in this bizarre
position
to seize a moment once again a war like
in france
disorganizes the government
throws the government into a very bad
reputation because it is the government
that loses world war one has to withdraw
as you know uh bresslatovsk and all of
that and the government collapses and
the army revolts
and in that situation a very small
political party
russian social democratic workers party
um splits under the pressures of all of
this
into the bolshevik and menshevik
divisions lenin trotsky and the others
are in the bolshevik division and to
make a long story short he's in exile
his position lenin's position
makes him gets him deported because he
says russian workers should not be
killing
german workers i mean this is a war of
capitalists who are dividing the world
up into colonies and russian working
people have no
should not kill and should not die for
such a thing
as you can expect
they arrest him and they throw him out
interestingly in the united states the
the comparable leader at that time of
the socialist party here
as you know there was no communist party
at this point that comes later
um the head of the socialist party a
very important american figure
named eugene victor debs
makes exactly the same argument to the
the americans should not fight in the
war
uh he's in the pa he has nothing to do
with london i don't even know if they
knew of each other but uh he does it on
his own he gets arrested and put in jail
here in the united states
by the way he runs for president from
jail and does very well really very well
remarkable
um and he's the inspiration for bernie
sanders if you if you see the link
um although he had much more courage
politically than bernie has that's
really interesting i'd love to return to
that link maybe later yes
history rhymes yes the complicated story
anyway the importance in terms of
marxism is that now
this seizure of power
by a group of marxists
that is a group of people inspired by
marx developing what you might call a
russian
uh even though there were differences
among the russians too but a russian
interpretation
this now
has to be transformed from a critique of
capitalism
into a plan at least what are you going
to do
in the soviet union
and a lot of this was then trial and
error marx never laid any of this out
probably wouldn't have been all that
relevant if he had because it was 50
years earlier in another country etc
so what begins to happen and you can see
how this happens then more later in
china and cuba and vietnam and korea and
so on
is that you have kind of a bifurcation
much of marxism remains
chiefly the critique of capitalism
but another part of it becomes
a set and they differ from one to the
other a set of notions
of what an alternative
post-capitalist society ought to look
like how it ought to work
and there's lots of disagreement about
it
lots of confusion
um and i would say that that's still
where it is that you have a tradition
now
that has these two major wings critique
of capitalism notion of the alternative
and then a variety of each of those and
that would be the framework in which i
would answer that's what marxism is
about
its basic idea if you had to have one
is that human society
can do better than capitalism and it
ought to try
you